gang come see the boys at an rug garbage
Live show tickets are moving quick and
all tickets are available at rug
garbage.com
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find it
out they grew up to be classy yeah
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash I'm your host H Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toties in the new edition the
holiday season is in full swing is upon
us yes sir and she's upstairs making her
famous fire alarm
eggnog you know why they call it fire
alarm eggnog why cuz you get so drunk
you pull the fire alarm Okay mik Coos is
coming at from across the table that's a
that's a win baby quite literal on that
one he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
international businessman with ties to
East German television what he told me
when he gave me the gig what are you
wearing a bunker give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan everybody what up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate if you subscribe on iTunes we
got the full Video available yoube as
you know those numbers are T cooking
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time one of the greatest
websites of all time you go over there
you go to
www.patreon.com
garbage you can get a bajillion hours of
bonus content there you go and also you
head over to
www.ar.com and you get tickets to all
the goor live shows there you go scoop
them up gang few ticks left for that
Philly show grab them Philly show it's
all going quick we got a theater show in
DC get tickets to that that was
rescheduled we'll see you down air in
December it's going to be a freaking
hoot mhm and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer X short and
air the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the te's and he
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone MC
scruffs Toby McMullen everybody what up
boys what up T-Bone nothing man nice
crisp air out there keeping it fresh
having a real nice time can I say
something you're going to get upset
about probably welcome to the
show you're
boo uh I don't know how to put this God
that means it's bad it's not bad it's
not good I'm just I'm as a friend you're
crossing over into lady haircut I would
I would let them know you're slightly
crossing over into lady haircut you got
a little bit of an ant Trish Vibe you
got a lady haircut all right this is
what we're doing this is how we starting
off I just thought of it do you own
mirrors to follow around insults like
that is crazy I'm aware of what I look
like physically but when it comes I mean
I'm I'm
folically you have a good head of hair
and I know how to take care of it I
listen man if you want to walk around
with ant Trish head D go ahead I'm just
telling you she's boofing you up a
little bit in the back you look like you
look like a single ant in the80s who's
trying to get it back together and latch
on to something the job's going good if
you started walking in here and sneakers
and putting heels on I wouldn't be
surprised you got real on the go cut
just I'm I'm just saying sure that let
it grow out a little bit and when you go
in there tell her not to give you that
angle you look you're about to ask for
the manager all right man [__]
Stonewall from T-Bone over there who I
genuinely think is upset I'm trying to
look out for
you listen I I am in no way I am in no
place to throw cast uh to throw throw
smoke at it's not even about that you're
looking out for a friend if you had a
booger or Brad bad breath I would tell
you you got lady cut yeah well maybe do
it not on the [__] air right off rip
this is what we do what are you talking
about that's crazy that's a crazy way to
start the show what do you want to talk
about the stock market I don't even know
where that is I think they're closed
today man tensions are high here I'm
telling you I I didn't know you were
going to freak out which she which even
makes you more lady
cut really lost this I'm not getting any
ass tonight I can tell you that seems be
sleeping on the couch he like you two
got some of that fire alarm eggnog
already going at it hey it wouldn't be
the holidays if we weren't fighting H
boys Merry Christmas pal we're in the
season happy Easter
too oh God and what was that thing on
your finger I got to be honest I was
playing with knives
earlier
man uh I have two knives uh pocket
knives uh
one I'm pretty I was I was always a big
knife guy I I collected pocket knives at
an early age um I don't know why I just
thought they were cool you're a weird
little kid I as a weird little kid seven
eight years old everybody loved the
pocket knife course who didn't you Swiss
Army ones it felt like a you felt like a
real man and uh never had the tweezers
they always went quick they lost the
tweezers and the toothpick too that was
gross yeah never never kept swis Army
knives to me were for dorks that was
that was nerd stuff you need a real
quick [__] somebody in the Boy Scouts
had one of those n it wasn't it wasn't
my cup of tea you need I always thought
that was weird what the Boy Scouts yeah
I mean I they're in a little bit of hot
water and they were doing that thing
everybody suspected for [__] 50 years
yeah which is crazy remember my buddies
were like yeah we're going away for the
Boy Scouts right yeah no I had one buddy
and the Boy Scouts uh we made fun of
them I mean like relentlessly right n
was this the '90s you're [__] tanning
the Boy Scouts you're catching some heat
no I mean that was play basketball dude
something yeah man those outfits were so
corny to me if they if they just wor
pants it' look sweet I'd rather they
should have dressed them up like
soldiers it would have looked cool I
think that was kind of the they were
going for that it was like very military
esque you know what I mean not with not
with a pair of knee knockers on showing
the G those high socks hey buddy get a
pair of ankle socks it's the goddamn 90s
some camos and [__] everybody would have
signed up then sure if you were rolling
around like SEAL Team Six out there pair
of slacks I would have been it but then
like they had like the shoulder stuff
going and like the tassels it's like boy
hey a pitch a 10 what are you doing
let's let's talk about trying to get
your hands on some heaters that should
be a badge let me get the heater
badge uh can you score booze at the
grocery store I know see what's what no
uh I agree a buddy had it a buddy was in
it like I got I always understood the
early you want to do the Cub Scout like
the early yeah you're seven eight nine
10 I get that that's you know fun
activities I'm I'm totally with that it
teaches some stuff cool whatever I don't
think you can judge anybody for any
activity they did while they were
children of course right that is that
that's what it is it was once you got
like if you were I played soccer yeah
that's F it's the world's most popular
sport what are you talking about uh and
I had a perm when I did it uh if you're
driving to your Cub Scout meetings
that's a tough look if you're physic
like if you got a driver's license and
you're not trying to get laid you're
going to [__] learn how to start a
fire or whatever once these Boy Scouts
T-Bone can you get a look is it Boy
Scouts Cub Scouts Eagle Scouts Eagle
Scouts that's they sound like snipers
that's pretty sweet an eagle scout they
sound like
virgins what are you talking and don't
got the cookies either Le the birds they
got the cooks well I think that's what
it it's it was very
girl scouty to me I was team Girl Scout
yeah who was because every spring they
rolled out those shortbreads shout out
to it oh I love those things um that was
my foray in the shortbread cookies and
they weren't that bad they were pretty
good they were all good oh all their
cookies were good but the shortbread
would be the you know least the most
basic yeah but uh I was playing two
knives I was playing with knives today I
this morning this morning what were you
doing the stabby thing n it's just kind
of you know showing off for a bunch of
boys
this what a real man does I was uh I
don't know just [__] around with
knives all right I would like to be a
pocketknife guy okay I just I'm not
pocketknife with a holder on the Belt no
you got to be so just a pocket knife in
your pocket mhm I don't know about that
I know that's a concealed weapon and New
York get weird too New York has real
weird there was always the every dirt
bag knows the Palm was that did you guys
know that the palm the
palm than my pal I'm allow but I'm like
that's not a that's not a thing is it I
don't know I don't know if that's an
actual I don't know if it would hold up
in court it's smaller than my but I
remember as a young kid I'm like
everybody's P what do you want to do
with this pocketknife not for protection
I want to be a guy cuz you can't get
those things out quick no you're jammed
up I want to be a guy that carries one
pull up the tweezers [__] I think like
when you have one you're a guy you're a
cool guy like four times a year anybody
got a pocket knife and what you want to
open packages for people guess I don't
know all right yeah I'm not proud but I
cut myself and then I duct tape it that
didn't work and I duct tape it again
that didn't work how bad were you
bleeding it's going to as I've started
moving it now that we recording it's
slowly starting to bleed again a
littleit let me see that little thing
get out of here I'm not saying I got bit
by a shark but it's I'm not worried
about the cut I'm worried about the
blood getting all over stuff put some
superglue on it my friend Toby McMullan
told me that oh we're friends now are we
uh Rel
sweetheart bro's got a little attitude
on you're digging yourself deeper big
guy I don't know why he's taking such
personal offense to it we're having a
nice time here we're not I'm having a I
having a good time [__] throwing
disparages at me with your duck tail
over there get I'm about to be a pocket
knife Guy moving forward next time you
guys see me out there in the streets I'm
going be a a a [__] PK boy I'd like
to get in some type of B way you where
you I get you have to get full lady cut
like frosted tips and stuff like that
feathered bangs feathered bangs my [__]
looks tight dude my flow is sick I don't
know what you're talking about all right
all right sure but I mean I think you
could use a cut too big guy I'm aware
yeah I can use a little trim trying to
figure out what I want to do with it I'd
start with a cut I think I just want to
let it grow I kind of have it in the I
have it in the position where it needs
to be to let it grow all the um uh
specifications are there the length of
the side the length of the top and the
length of the back so as it grows in
it'll it'll it'll all grow the right way
sure it's been pruned let's say that
okay yeah I've been pruned sounds like a
sounds like a fancy way say you've been
too lazy to get a haircut between you
and me but hey prun away will you
something about my noodle no it's also
you're at you're at the hair length
where you know you like a cocktail from
time to time enjoy Co specifically after
a couple of shows we'll go out we'll get
some cocktails and drinks that's when
you get frazzled it's not the drinks
it's it's the it's the [__] doobage
that's when that's when I go off the
rails and then as your hair is longer
you grab it and you dude I mean I'm
making points holding you look over it
looks like you got electrocuted you look
like [__] doc from Back to the Future
dude yeah no I I agree look like an
idiot yeah um yeah but I think I'm going
to let it grow okay yeah like how like I
don't know you know it depend it depends
how quickly the weight keeps coming off
because in the end I see myself uh I'd
love to I'd love to hear
this I see myself with longer hair and
and a nice beard okay so you want like
actually long hair like like like you're
going have like T-Bones length down past
my neck but it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be as uh curly it wouldn't be as thick H
okay and have it nice and trimmed I was
getting there but then I was just
getting too
fat still fat obviously that's I'm
saying if I'm trying to time it all out
so you know okay yeah I'm just I don't
know if I trying to time it off for like
the next 50 lbs you know 50 lbs another
50 lbs off like long hair where you
would like tuck behind your ears yeah I
I was at that point last summer I could
tuck I was tucking it behind my
ears yeah tucking my nuts back that that
wasn't long that wasn't like a long
haircut haircut that was just like like
that was still B cutes no it was bll cut
I had I had it going in the back what
are you talk I could put it in a
ponytail
it was that wasn't a long haircut
haircut though you know what I mean that
wasn't like you you didn't like have it
down here everything still went it long
hair that went back it's going to go
back I'm going to put it back I'm going
to put it I'm slick it back that's how I
do it all right you don't like it I know
I just can't see I don't I can't see it
that's right you don't have the vision
sure maybe but that's what I'm trying to
do is I'm trying to Vision down the road
okay as I as I as I make my preparations
okay yeah all right hey to each their
own I'm
uh I can't wait to see the stages of it
uh somebody commented somebody DMD or
something or a picture of you of the
many iterations of H Foley there has
been in this podcast the shaved head the
beard the shaved face the mustache there
was times where ear like I guess later
into the pandemic once once toies once
we were in the basement you were going
you'd come in bald one day long hair the
next day I spinning
plates keep the [__] keep the tax man
off your back I don't know f i a know
fly here that guy's got a mustache I
keep the conversation moving in the
right direction but I like to do that I
do that I do it uh it's more of a
spiritual thing with me oh God okay
spiritual sure it's when I feel it you
know what I mean a lot of times when we
go when we go back to the island when we
go to Hawaii I you know I I that's a
very cathartic experience for me I like
to buzz it all off shave it I'm never
shaving again I'm never make never never
am I making that mistake again yeah it's
not a great look on anybody really
unless you got a good jaw yeah but not
most people don't have great jaw no a
little everybody's got a little
something I wish I was doing it my ho I
wish I was doing it when I was a kid I
remember I I would I would fall under
the peer pressure of Patty you're not
shaving shave you got to shave we're
going to church you're both in there
shaving your mustach how dare
you now they Ed something back in the
day I don't know what the what what what
what what they were using nare was big
which I never remember my Aunt Kathy WIP
off hair my Aunt Kathy using nare dude
that had to [__] take years off of
Our Lives sure just sitting there in a
[__] small little house in the middle
of the summer with no AC and just this
chemical smell there was another thing
it's like a train fell over there was a
big big [__] uh they got jammed up
didn't they is that no good chemicals I
you're wiping [__] hair follicles off
your body the one I think it was called
Epi stop and spray what the
[__] was that it yeah it was Epi sto and
spray hold on Apple Apple sto and
spray stop and spr hepatitis hair
removal dude and it was early
2000s uh same [__] you put it on wipe it
away early 2000s they remember like The
infomercials but it wasn't like a full
infomercial it was like an infomercial
commercial you know what I mean it was
like a little longer than a regular it
was would run in a regular commercial
block but it would be a little longer it
wasn't like a 30 second spot I remember
those broads from pratic they [__]
moved merch I don't know that that is
either you don't remember that the acne
stuff prostatic prostatic it was an acne
medication all you kids were taking it
it was proactive yeah proactive sorry
pratic sounds like a
DJ
boo you take proactive oh yeah it ruins
your hand towels bleaches the [__] it it
turned those women into billionaires
billionaires billionaires they launched
another thing which I think one's a
pyramid scheme oh yeah shout out to it's
all like you sell to people type that
kind of there you go real cut [__] Vibes
yeah but that that one they turned them
into billionaires that proactive stuff
but this it worked it like actually
worked I think so yeah um what was it a
wash or a pill it was like a a a three
step washing process you had like
different stuff you'd put on but what
was really gnarly is your skin would
become addicted to the proactive so then
the second you stopped doing it was a
straight pizza face shout out to them
BRS they knew what they were doing there
you go give them a little taste give
them a little taste of what [__] of
what punon Tang feels like keep these
nerds coming back sure what did you did
you have bad acne as a kid oh yeah you
did yeah on my back too oh that kid was
weird look like you're taking steroids
in junior
high what the [__] oh man man [__]
Crater Face we had one friend that had
it pretty bad and this is before all
this stuff I think maybe you could get
that as a prescription in like my era or
they had some other stuff that you could
get as a prescription cuz the other crap
didn't work that's why it was like
proactive was I felt like that was that
the first thing that start like really
worked for kids you know what I mean and
helped him out but he would just rock
him because his doctor told him if you
[__] with them you'll get scarring and
dude he would roll in with [__] snow
caps like dude
go eat over there will you
fck [__] throw up my salami and jeans
good kid I like it yeah uh kick rocks K
but talk about Adam and Eve put
something in your butt gang we ain't
talking about your stockings gang uhuh
talking it's Christmas time do yourself
a favor get a little weird for the
holidays get over to Adam and ID grab
something pick it up stick it in stick
it out do whatever you want to do you
could do it with a partner or by
yourself whatever you choose or a group
whatever you want we don't talking we
don't dispar over big man's language uh
it's the holidays yeah and the best
thing about them they got the discreet
shipping you know what I mean nobody
knows no one knows not like Santa
rolling in with the sack and stuff like
that [__] dildos hanging out that's
how you get jammed up I'm talking uh if
you're ordering something you don't want
anybody to know to the whole
neighborhood if you live in a building
you don't want you know from www.
boner.com uh it's fantastic uh and don't
wait better sex is just a click away
take 50% off one item and free shipping
with free Rush processing so you don't
lose that hard on just go to Adam
andeve.com and select any one item and
use the code garbage at checkout uh this
is an exclusive offer for just our
listeners be sure to use code garbage to
get your discount 100% free shipping and
Rush processing that's Adam and eve.com
promo code garbage Adam and eve.com
promo Cod garbage do it K this is Aura
bring your family together with aura
frames Ora frames baby we all got them
we love them upload pictures it sits
right on the uh the nightstand on the
counter or in the kitchen where I have
it so when I go get my late night snack
I can say there's the kid he's doing
good in Little League you can even put
it on a credenza ooh who's got money for
credenzas not me uh but it's fantastic
um listen if I you're nuts if you think
every person in my family is getting an
or frames this holiday season that's
what you're getting everybody Denise
already has one I'm getting her one down
to put down there in Wildwood so she can
stay on top of the kitties you know what
I mean uh it's fantastic uh you can
upload a video message to play on the
frame as soon as you plug it in I didn't
know that yeah that's what they're doing
like I said they're bringing families
together uh right now Ora is offering
their best deal of the year for Cyber
Monday listeners can save on the perfect
gift by visiting Oraf frames.com garbage
that's Aura a a frames.com garbage use
the promo code garbage you get $40 off
their bestselling frames terms and
conditions apply G get over there yeah
but dude that [__] Apple stop and
spray I think it was the first time I
actually you would see like they would
show a Woman They with the bikini areas
they call it as the medical term I
believe is the bikini area and they
would show like oh don't get razor bumps
use thatle stop and spr and it was like
a me it was remember like a I always
pictured it was like a like a skin so
Sal like the like the bug spray oh that
skin soof it was like a similar spray
bottle to that like a white bottle in
that shape I used to slap it with that
Skin So Soft Jesus not a sker in sight
huh what the hell keep the dicks away
spanking it with bug spray that's not
bug spray light light a couple
citronella candles I'm trying to get in
the mood here that stuff was like it's
not bug no it's not it's Skin So Soft I
used it as bug spray because they found
out that you could dick so
hard yeah that's what I'm talking about
ain't nothing soft about that baby I
used it as bug spray yes because they
found out that it kept bugs away but
that just could have been some lady from
Avon that went to some lady's house and
was like you know what it's good on bugs
too cuz it didn't smell great it wasn't
great as a
moisturizer but it did keep I don't know
that's what we were told it kept the
mosquitoes away which I feel like back
in the day weren't there a lot more
mosquitoes around than there are now
here we go that's such an H Foley line
there was okay you just don't go outside
I mean you're not I'm I'm acting if I'm
outside I hike hunt fish all right we've
reached the lying portion of the show
I'm outside back to fville gang not
nearly as much as you were a kid why
can't you just accept those facts fine
thank you what the [__] why do you why
do you you dig your feet in on these
things that are just made up I'll tell
you what he's got the know- it- all box
in front of him see if there's more
mosquitoes less mosquitoes now than
there was in the '90s this is one of
those things you're right about but your
thought process is wrong I guarantee I'm
right do they think they have a sker
count too yeah they know how manying
census every four years yeah of course
they know how many mosquitoes there are
they just sprayed for something a few
months ago I can't remember what it was
I mean I don't know how you do stuff
like this he's right I knew he was it
was one of those things he's right about
it's crazy course of course L skers yeah
if there's one thing I've learned in
this show is there was a time there was
a time when you were wrong about
everything and I remember you just
pivoted and you're right about so much
[__] now it's crazy I read I'm a
reader I like books and periodical
there's less mosquitoes now than there
was yes but this is according to PBS
Wisconsin so I don't know I could just C
public programming that could just be in
Wisconsin that could be due to all the
for you don't know that check in
Pennsylvania you don't live in
Pennsylvania I guarantee you there's
less mosquitoes in Pennsylvania I don't
I don't see you when I'm down there I
never see him in the city never see a
mosquito and the only time I think we
got bit by mosquitoes was when we were
somewhere was it down in Florida or
something like that the Florida forget
about it from 1979 to
2022 uh 71% of the
places uh whatever annual or uh whatever
studied experienced an increase no
experienced an increase in annual
mosquito dates from six by about 16 days
on average that's a rig that's rig
that's a rig test we got the PBS
Minnesota what do you mean that's who
we're going this from climate Central
that sounds made
up yeah what else did they they probably
got a ghost kitchen there from hippies
right.org uh no that's the first thing
that comes up it seems like there's less
no increased temperatures and more
frequent flooding events cause mosquito
populations to flourish and provide
conditions that could enable a
non-native species such as the Asian
tiger mosquito to be more esta I don't
like that oh man that's a mean looking
guy doing karate on you yikes yeah I
don't like that yeah but I don't know
what do you think T-Bone I got you know
a lot of people are saying a lot of
things about these mosquitoes man yeah
some are saying there's more some are
they saying less huh no it's more
everything I'm seeing is more damn I
mosquito this is a different should have
walked away from the table should have
ended the show right
there this is a different Source
mosquito populations have increased as
much as tfold how come we don't see them
that much when I'm when I'm down at
patties I don't see mosquitoes you're
also listen I see lightning bugs and I
see I see a lot more ladybugs yeah but
you also have a protective layer of
marbor light around you at all time
that's true very true the Iron Dome yeah
you have a Burnie atmosphere that they
can't that they cannot
penetrate oh the ozone you need over at
the fly
house seal this thing up uh but I don't
think skin soft originally was a bug
spray cuz I never the name never made
sense to me yeah it was skin so it was
supposed to be a moisturizer but I think
they used it or I'm telling you one of
these broads was sick of getting was
sick of striking out and not not selling
nothing you know it's also good for
skers for skers and that was when
everybody was playing little league
everybody had soccer games and football
games an off Family oh yeah yeah very I
never I would I would rather love to
smell of that would rather fight the
mosquitoes than have that stuff on
you're crazy that worked like a charm
you rub yourself in peanut butter they
still would get you smelled like [__] it
was sticky I love that smells like
summer to me baby no I hated it I
[__] hated it huh never like we were
also never a big suntan lotion we were
never a big
preventative product family Sun we dealt
after we were an aloe we were a [__]
uh c c what is it chamomile te no Campo
phenique what the [__] hey what no what
was the calamine lotion oh yeah use that
all heavy and calamine lotion that would
dry on you oh man heavy and [__] we
were we were always dealing with
problems we never got out in front of
them of course of course never sunscreen
a lot of suntan lotion a lot of that
Tropicana uh coconut stuff in the Black
Bottle or the brown bottle that smells
like hot r
that stff
I yeah it was all right man Jackie
momano or something like that or Marino
those are cherries was the Lifeguard at
the at our community pool at Town Line
and man she would drown herself in that
[__] mhm first time I saw a woman in a
bikini yeah there was this girl that
worked the sit there and eat my Choco
Taco that worked the sunglasses on ooing
at her the snack bar at the at the my
buddy swim club that he belonged to we
went her name was Kendall first time I
ever heard that name man she must have
been I think she was 18 we were probably
13 or 12 or something that's it she
might as well be 38 buddy I ordered
about 80 orders of chicken fingers that
day just get some eyes on Kendall you
know what I mean I remember being like
that's a woman a winner over that's a
woman yeah dude meanwhile I'm swimming
in my
shirt man that's a tough place for a
fact sliding enough to die with all your
Skin So Soft
on oh Dam yeah it was tough calamine
lotion that was all right calamine
lotion iodine that was for uh Poison Ivy
and stuff that's what we used it for
yeah skin irritations yeah cof phenique
was um
a uh it was an antiseptic they also have
copen copen cold sore medicine but back
in the day it was it had a it was like
iodine it came with oh it came with a
dropper but it wasn't a Dr it was just a
little piece of plastic that went into
it and you would just rub it on there
vaguely remember that seemed like Civil
War stuff to me like you were getting
ready to amputate an arm or something I
don't know if iodine worked I know uh
iodine Works did it benine works iodine
that brown stuff that's iodine isn't it
it's benad it's a little bit different
cuz I remember Patty was in on the
ground floor that cuz she worked at a a
professional facility that had doctor's
office she used to come home with like
the surgical ones of those well the ones
they what they what what they wipe when
they give you the like an ID that's Ben
I always thought it was iodine now huh
it's not iodine's a little bit redder I
think the iodine was the precursor to
benine you got anything on that all I
got on iodine is it's a chemical element
it's symbol one in atomic number 53 the
heaviest of the stable halogens I don't
know what any any of that means is that
a stable hallogen I know oh yeah the
stailista iodine medical use okay you
both of you idiots hacking away I don't
know what I'm talking about I is used to
treat and prevent iodine deficiency what
the f and as an antiseptic yeah yeah I'm
telling you that's what it started look
up benad that's the hot [__] right now
everybody uses that they use that in my
uh in my my hoof videos that I like to
watch now all the cows man hit me give
me some skin on that those are all right
bro I've looked into it I don't
understand about doing that about
dipping and doing that as a career yeah
all right so for the listener there's
these things of like something a cow had
a cow or it's usually it's usually Liv
it's like cows yeah they have a some
sort of uh infection in their hoof that
it's cracked and it gets in there gets
dirty or a rock or something gets in
there it causes a lot of damage and and
the the I don't know black Smith or
whatever they are it's not a blacksmith
yeah blacksmith don't they aren't they
the guy that Hooves people no they they
would make the shoe yeah blacksmith is
his iron work like okay I thought the
blacksmith would make if he make the
Horseshoe he would put it on you'd put
on a horse he got time to do that he's
making horses shoes all day you go to a
third party a faer a faer those they got
those sharp ass kniv they're like the
curved blades and they trim away they
find it they clean it and then they yeah
they get down there then and then they
they put a little pad on it and wrap it
up and they show the nice little cow
walking away that's so sad how good does
that feel they can't walk in poor little
guys then they then they hook them up
they pull out like a like a drywall
screw yeah take care of them yeah have
you ever seen like completely unclipped
like horse Hooves or that like curl
up like those wild like Marchi shoes
those things are nuts they come up with
like the cobras on the ends those guys
are flexing what are you an Italian
waiter get out of here yeah I don't like
that at all how do you driving
those sorry the
shoes [__] three I didn't like that
when when when that stuff hit really
hard those the longer shoe sure that was
your guy's [__] a little bit that that
came back I couldn't AF I wasn't I
wasn't dressing smart casual back then
and never had anywhere to go to wear
them I'd maybe get like an old pair from
my brother if I had to go to a wedding
or a funeral you weren't dressed in
Urban Chic at the time no yeah but I
those things sucked uhhuh I hated those
we were I always just took a pair of my
brothers so they were always a little
too big to begin with by a size or when
when they they got longer when they fell
out of fashion they fell hard so I'd be
wearing them the next summer to
something like what the I remember one
time it was somewhere I thought I was
cool I had like you know my pair of
Express boot cut jeans on that were like
you know a little wider at the bottom
they had some design on the Jean I had a
button up on white white T-shirt under
it you could probably see whatever the
whatever a pair of flippers on whatever
the design was and I had the they were
long in the front but then boxed you
know what I mean I hated the Box the
straight toes the squared off toe hated
that look like a Marine's haircut man
highing tight on them on them bad boys
and like runaway elf my brother's buddy
Nikki shout out to Nikki pull me aside
he goes lose the square toes dude I
thought I look I had Legos on my feet I
thought I was so cool he goes lose the
square toes hey Frankenberry get a pair
of
Sketchers
I dress man that was a tough time when I
was in my early 20s it was cool to get
dressed up the
button-ups you went to like a cool bar I
couldn't afford any and I was just
always behind always always always
always behind man now you're at the
Forefront of fashion hey clean Hooves
anyway oh God all right let's quit
screwing around here all right it's a
family episode you know it baby as the
homies and the bozos know when you sign
up for the old patreon there get a
question red on the air by Kippy and uh
the fat
man you ain't lying uh all right let's
get into it this is uh this one's from
Travis shout out of never had one read
is it garbage have used Dance Dance
Revolution arcade game as your primary
source of exercise hated that [__] man
couldn't do it so jealous they would get
cooking threw so much shade at it people
were that's what they were doing for the
night they were going out I can picture
T-Bone being good at it the Dance Dance
Revolution horrible really no
coordination how' you do it's like
Guitar Hero and rock band I hated that
[__] hated that [__] hold on hit me the
boy could shred I was melting faces I'd
whammy all that [__] that probably was
popular I'm I'm what from 47 now that
became popular I was early 15 years ago
I was probably
21 okay so you're I was in college yeah
oh I was like 18 to eight yeah probably
19 so I knew people in their proper 30s
that were that like went and got that
got got that guitar sure what was that
PlayStation it was foro it was all of
them okay went and got and then got the
rock band thing and then you'd walk in
you'd walk into somebody's somebody's
house to buy weed or something you'd see
a [__] Studio that weird drum kit
sitting in the corner I could [__] I
was on the Skins dude get out of here I
was the Dork going well I can play Real
Guitar so this isn't even yeah that's
right but can you play Real Guitar yeah
I used to be able to h no way yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah did you know that I did not
I got I got some chords in a pentatonic
scale okay but now I I've start ban
T-Bone what are we doing dude I fell on
my wrist skating too much now I can't
hold it for more than 30 seconds my my
wrists are sure you're out
uh sit back there and look pretty will
you uh um yeah I
uh Guitar Hero is Big also real dirt bag
move shout out to my uh my a friend of
mine who will R nameless but Reen remain
namess will remain nameless we were
riding around in uh my Chevy Lumina my
95 96 Chevy Lum I believe we're in
college okay rock band so Guitar Hero
came out that was just a guitar and then
there was Rumblings of oh they're going
to do a they're they're coming out with
a drum set you're like what the [__]
that's crazy
so that dropped and uh I was riding
around with my boys Pat Uh Phil X and a
couple other guys and I was the only one
had a car in the city so I was driving
to get a a big screen TV or something
right which I remember we bought the
floor model and we I was so embarrassed
they were really beating them up over
over like 10 bucks for the floor model
so it didn't come with a box so we had
to shove it in the back seat of my car
like already set up with like the stand
on it and [__] oh man tough look and uh
my one buddy uh he's uh he he took rock
band took the price tag off covered it
with like a DVD of like you know I don't
know [__] One Tree Hill or something
sure slapped that on it was that $29.99
took it up to the cash register and I'm
like and they ring it up and the guy's
like $29.99 this isn't right this these
are like
$598 and my buddy's like okay I'll put
it back and then just went to another
cash register and the guy went $29.99
man that's real cheap he's like yeah I
don't know dude just [__] walked with
it I was like damn Veterans Day sale but
I would I would have fallen right at the
okay yeah I'm sorry I wouldn't have
tried again he got right up on that
horse cleaned off his
hopes took him right out baby and you
got a big screen TV in Rock Band big
screen TV Rock Bound set it up at the
[__] house and also at that same time
they had Stadium couch seating they
found a they had a couch they found
another couch on the street somebody was
throwing out and they put it on cinder
blocks behind the first couch nice man
that was the [__] Thunderdome that
place that's pretty sweet uhhuh but yeah
never got into uh what is it called
Dance Dance Dance Revolution now well it
be I respect the moves Scott Pilgrim did
it when he was on when he was on his F
date with the with the with with his
lady uh-huh uh it also became one of
those I mean commenting on comment on a
guy like that was like your buddy that
you went to school with as a [__]
movie character in the movie yeah sure
it's good film haven't seen it really
what about that thinks that I'm into
that you've seen it it's awesome awesome
sure T to force I'm not saying it's bad
plus a nice little Cameo from that Chris
Evans oh yeah not my cup of tea my
Captain America's not e cup of day Chris
Evans gu's a National
Treasure okay yeah know it's not my cup
of tea you know this about me it's a
good movie I never said anything bad
about it I just said it's not my next
time we're on the road I'll put it on on
a Saturday afternoon we'll watch it
together no I got you a Get Shorty I'll
get you with this seen Get Shorty I've
seen parts of Get Shorty yes I have you
shorty shout out to Wawa [__] hogy
Fest keep the kids coming back I can
show you some dance moves in
there you want to see a boy do the
electric slide down the WWA IC tea aisle
Hit Me No but that was that order and he
going extra May
perfect that was they were all kind of
the same Vibe same understanding of like
it's now a physical the the video game
is a physical there's a physical
manifestation to the video game that got
kids back into the arcade though so I
like that they also the thing that
changed about that it's big in Japan
that was started in Japan huge
everybody's like okay same thing with
guitar here like this like it was like
this is fun I'm doing the dance I'm one
two you're getting some exercise but
then they hack it and they're like you
just hold on to that back [__] like it
was very like you know uh same thing
with the guitar here where they they've
hacked it to be like they're amazing at
it so it's either like you suck at it or
you're the there was no real like middle
ground it was either became like an
expert this might be a contral your mom
doing it this might be a controversial
statement too but I always thought the
Wii could kick
rocks um hated that [__] I agree it
never it was cool also the first time
you're like this is such a unique thing
to video game hitting each other with
those remotes sure with the bowling I
got to be honest I was playing it with
like my 10 and 8-year-old nephews they
were all SM smoked yeah they were little
dicks about it too uh but dude when we
bowling if you had like five guys there
was nothing really going on Tuesday
night in the summer again we were in
college like there's nothing to do not
going to the bar get like 230 racks and
just [__] Bowl all night ay Machi
boys I'm throwing rocks tonight Lady
Killers look out that was a good time
man you're all wearing bowling
shoes slipping on the carpet there was
also too I remember the first time Phil
X told me that you just had to do this
you know what I mean like you could play
tennis and just do this oh no that's not
true you got you got to really wind it
up far as far as I'm concerned no so
dude I was running into the walls and
stuff and he was just [__] sitting
there like that I what the [__] dude K
be going back man I was [__] I was
trying to be like save it between my
legs and stuff
yeah [__] had me running baby great
question yeah um all right let's see
here this one's from Justin $10 Hogie
here there you go are you garbage if you
crumble up a Pop-Tart and put it in a
bowl add milk and eat it like cereal no
that's ice cream too that's amazing hot
one ice cream chop it up throw it over
top of ice cream or on the bottom you
put in the meric for uh for a few
seconds and then slap some ice cream on
top of it incredible that's a that yeah
I mean that's more of a dessert but
that's the
crumbled up that is cereal is [__]
all right it's great you can't get that
you can get the idea of ice cream on top
of a warm Pop-Tart at a restaurant I
mean it's not a Pop-Tart it's some sort
of cookie or brownie or something only
problem is that exists you would need
more than one double bag of Pop-Tarts to
get a bowl and then you're that that's
heavy heavy bike sugar sure it have to
be a smaller portion yeah small bowl
Pop-Tart Ice Cream Sandwich would be
incredible great you know who does the
it's great I've done it really yeah I've
done everything you could do with a
Pop-Tart you you make them you make them
and then put them back in the freezer
and they Harden yeah it's pretty good
yeah I've seen it done yeah my only
gripe I say it all the time 10% more
filling well they then they did have the
doubles didn't they what I'm almost
positive I didn't know that I could be
wrong or the XX I feel like there was
like an XX you're thinking Oreos no I'm
not really that's I'm you don't think
the people in product development have
thought I could have I could be totally
wrong it's it's I feel like the s'mores
one had way more filling maybe didn't
love those that was they never really
got there either theide that was New Age
[__] the chocolate ones are the best the
double stuffed uh pop out does not exist
but there is a petition on change.org
there we go this is what we're talking
about there's only 118 signatures I
think we can bump that up ni yeah I mean
if we could use our platform to better
the planet positive change in the world
just listen it's not you're not they're
not even that far away I'm sure it has
something to do with you know then you
got to put then the calories go up and
then all that kind of stuff because you
have to publish all that stuff when you
have a big National brand like that sure
but I mean like a little squirt just a t
you need I don't disagree I don't
disagree 10% 10% more of the the
frosting 10% more of the thing too I
didn't think about the frosting frosting
was a little thin frosting was a little
thin
sometimes you get a bad one where they
stopped a little too short you're like
feel like I'm eating [__] British
cookies or something they make this on a
Friday what's going on quit and time
let's go this feels like one of those
things that that like when you look at
the corporate numbers on it it's like
that increase cost them 1.2 billion but
they would make it up they would charge
10 cents at whatever it is they can
offset the cost they already got the
filling to t-bone and those things ain't
cheap anymore I don't know if you bought
a pack of Pop-Tarts in the last couple
of years I was heavy bike on those
during the pandemic really oh yeah it's
crazy seven eight bucks I got myself
some Eggo waffles the other night good
for you it was all right good for you I
used to eat them just plain I'd come
home from school no one was home [__] we
know two throw them throw two of them in
there and they were so buttery they were
the best I felt like I was being healthy
too of I'm being
honest they said breakfast is the most
important part of the day why not have
it Choice that's what I'm saying B that
was a scam what no [__] that breakfast
this game can remember who it was it was
like Dr Kellogg Quaker Oats or Kellogg
or somebody yeah they [__] just you
know this is real important Grease the
right couple of people was back in the
day when everything was yeah three guys
could change everything grease it yeah
grease them Wheels
Daddyo they catch you in the speaky or
something like that this one's just
funny Jam me up this is from Long Dong
Silver is it garbage if a member of your
family was dishonorably discharged from
the military dot dot dot he was set up I
swear that's good uh I did know someone
who was uh dishonorably discharged
really yeah family friend yikes and I I
remember that's a real details did I do
I have them yeah uh yeah it was
something along the line of
drugs uh yeah storm the pharmacy it was
uh yeah it was something I forget the
exact details but I remember hearing
that of so and so was dishonorably
discharged I'm like what's that my mom
goes you can't even get a job at
McDonald's once that happens is that
true I don't know I know I know it's
frowned upon I know you're not your
resume is not moving to the top of the
stack I don't know much about
it I would have never told anybody I
just yeah I got
discharged well I yeah I guess that show
up with a duffel bag of
bills now where you guys keep the drugs
H uh I guess probably back in the day
before anything was computerized you I
would just say I wasn't in the military
if I had been the family knows I'm
saying the family and all those rats
started running their mouths it got back
to back to you well when you get your
ears stuff with egos well you get
discharged I mean if you join the
military for four years and then 6
months later you're back they're going
to have questions I'm saying you just
like n I'm
I'm a hero that I was kicking too much
ass what do you mean like they wanted to
keep it
fair God damn Lethal Weapon running
around yeah I don't know that feels like
one of those things that you don't
realize the reifications for it when
it's happening like it's like who just I
don't care like getting written up at a
restaurant job or whatever sure I was
always like okay that means nothing to
me yeah then they when they bring you
back in again they got you they really
do yeah why you they they were I was
always told never to never sign anything
oh when a manager would write sign
nothing but then they would just fire
you whatever well that I don't give a
[__] the [__] I care
um
I I I was if I I was in a union when I
worked at Acme it was like the what it
was technically the teamsters so they
would keep your job they weren't allowed
to fire you yeah and I would they would
just be like i' I ref buffalino
straightening you I know I'd be like I
refuse to sign here sign this right up
no thanks Dy okay when's Lind when's
Linda
start man [__] Jimmy haa pin
on hell no we won't
go yeah yeah they Jam me up with that
[__] they started getting wise I feel
like at restaurants with that especially
corporate ones because they it's all
like Doc you got to document everything
yeah because they would give like you
know some dirt ball like 15 warnings and
then they start like all right cuzz then
either yeah they didn't have any
anything on them so they started writing
it up and making you sign it I got they
popped me right as I started working at
Bear burger for no reason I think I was
like five minutes late it's never a
reason that's a reason there was no
reason ever I think I was like three
days I think they did it just to have
one on me keep me keep me keep me
playing ball [__] noses
running you think you think there's a
huge conspiracy he keep you in line I
thought that's what it was sure Hot Shot
coming in hot shot remember you begged
you I remember you getting that job too
how who did I
beg you had a friend the guy that got
you the job yeah that was you begged
yeah I did beg for that man this
distorted reality shout out to Tommy
yeah yeah you got it he was a comic yeah
yeah yeah I remember you were like I God
I remember that was like that was that
was that was news that went into my
[__] letters back home big man might
land the job at Bear Burger things are
looking up for the team jammed up uhhuh
I remember the bird took me at the
dinner after after they hired me what
the bear Burger when's that when's that
employee discount kick
in can I use that now I got up from the
table just walked over to my other table
with her yeah we're good we can
order take 20% off the top of this the
same
team yeah you had me in there for a free
meal too did you come in and have a meal
with me yeah no with me you made me sit
there alone while you were working he
thought which I looking back I never
understood do you remember that no come
in come in we'll have lunch or something
like go okay I show up and you're like
yeah I got I got a few more tables I got
to take care of and I just sat there and
had a burger with like an [__] by
myself good though I didn't dip you
either [__] service stunk I once took
a date to a a different location of the
restaurant I worked at so I could use my
employee discount did she know she did
not yeah I'm a
doctor I had to have a real discreet
conversation by the men's room with my
server sure at your restaurant job on
your days off is a tough look yeah I
just uh I just did a
real trashy embarrassing thing uh I was
recently back to your law office to get
a cup of
coffee
oh man pops in to see what's in the
fridge oh just fired up the old door
Dash and get a couple free fries I hated
that please they hated me too I was good
until they all hated us I was no I was
good there till it wasn't good and it
got bad it's always the way it went it
got bad so quick so quick it was always
the moment where you were like you know
what this is all right I I really like
it here it's cool the next day it would
start going downhill mhm manager got
fired oh they're changing this oh
they're changing that they're cutting
back hours so everyone's going to be
running around like an idiot they would
[__] always [__] it up yeah man [__]
um but I was in
Macy's and the girl man it's one of the
it's like a dad joke thing they like
girl you know she's like hey do you want
to open up uh you know Macy's credit
card while I was checking out I was like
uh no thanks I'm like and I I forget
exactly how I got in I'm like but I used
to I told her I'm like I used to work at
M I'm like showing her I know I'm like
you know I used to work at Macy's too
folding those panties Wrong by the way
you should be in your on your
head that it was very uh you guys still
sniff all the bras before you put them
up
on what were you moving over there were
you mov doing I was a men's habit daser
I worked in like casual men's I worked
in the I worked in the Levi section
killed that it was Levi's Nike my my my
my Straight domicile was Levis
Nike uh and like just some other kind of
random stuff sweatpants t-shirts that
kind of thing I didn't have I you were
an expert in sweatpants had to get a
boner in
them had I hide your
chubby I remember there was there was a
kid in junior ey a couple years ahead of
me that you like to push down and go
over the wa under the waistband man I
remember when I found out you could go
into the waistband that was a life s
I'm walking around with a loaded gun now
you guys go ahead of me man being dude I
remember I remember being in school
under a desk just like not me under but
at a desk you know legs and groin area
hidden by a desk thank God just being
like please looking at like six minutes
left before the Bell Rings thinking
about my grandma or something trying to
[__] talk this trying to talk this
guy off a ledge hey where is it
man now you go ahead I'll me your lunch
oh
god oh man all
right for best best uh best term I ever
heard for a
uh a random erection was a
nerb a no excuse Random
Boner kids got a
nerb there I am sitting in class
catching I catch a
nerve that's all right ain't it
ner sounds like something bad from a
game show no
nervs a man the nerb got you
[Laughter]
[__] ah nerb is good nerbs all right
yeah man say Give me the give me the
acronym again no excuse Random
Boner kids got a nerb going so they am
sitting history three
class man that's all right I didn't
think that was going to hit me that hard
nerb is
great no excuse
random we're having a good time over
here in this gosh Dar program this weird
to think about like G an excuse for this
boner I got no excuse sir I'm sorry you
came out of nowhere your honor I got a
note for my doctor it could happen at
any
moment yeah that was always that always
uh that was a real predicament and that
this was what happen yeah Jam yeah you
really had to yeah man tight pair of
jeans though and a longer shirt you'd be
all right yeah yeah well not too tight a
pair of jeans you needed something in
the middle yeah something that get
restricted but not also you know too
much friction also could be a bit
that I could just get him angry is that
pudding on your
shirt that's disgusting carrying your
school family show but I remind you
uhhuh um all right let's see here we got
time for a a couple more here uh this
one's from anon's wet dream uh are you
garbage if your dogs have health
insurance but you
don't it ain't CL I mean it's classy to
have do you guys have pet insurance no
is that a thing yeah we have it really
yeah yeah yeah you do uhhuh you got a
policy on them uh-huh I think a couple
hundred bucks a year and we've gotten
our money back for sure and then they
cover like almost everything got life
insurance on him too whole thing's in
his name what are you talking about poor
little guy got his pole prints all over
this thing guy's Marked for Death I
needed a pole
[Music]
man um you got insurance she got
insurance on them they say if you can do
it when they're
young I think I honestly think it was
like we did scratch pay when when when
when the kitty cat wasn't feeling good
before the pandemic what's that it's
like uh like a p it's when you grab a
scratch off on the way to the vet to
decide if you can Del live or
die no nerve no nerve no nerve damn it
two nervs in a row it's all riding on
pot of gold
[Laughter]
baby uh it was like they would it was
like a credit card for you know you
could hand it $1,000 bill at the far at
the vet okay and they would you you
would just start a scratch pay account
they would approve you for a certain
amount and then you paid it monthly so
you're kind of financing it yeah gotcha
interest rate wasn't that bad it was
actually a good tool and it helped us
out in [__] coming out of pocket 25 I
I was I couldn't have sure this pre-
pandemic I was jammed up yeah uh I think
we did I think I honestly think it was
like a couple hundred bucks for the year
and now I just took them for something W
he swallowed bones I took him I had to
go get him
x-ray I think I had to come out of
pocket like 220 and then we the bird
takes care of it she's on it that ain't
bad she keeps her paperwork in line they
sent us a check for 195 bucks back 220
is nothing 220 is nothing I got 195 back
dude it's written out the Hans my vet I
don't know where that [__] [__] where
where where they're coming up with those
numbers and they hit you they come out
with two printouts this is what it looks
like if you really want to you know and
then this is if you just want to keep up
appearances hey kids going to public
school all
right can either go through with the
surgery or here are some
sunglasses poor little key
cat um H let's see speaking speak of
scratchers this is fantastic this is
from Sean are you garbage if you save
scratch offs in your car and then when
you have enough hand them to the gas
station guy and say throw it all on pump
three I think that's the classiest
version of that no that's pretty good
have you ever had anybody try to trade
you a winning scratch of hair can I give
you this instead what do you mean
instead of cash oh I've done that yeah
you have well like around Christmas and
stuff when they're floating no no no no
no no no I'm
saying I owe you five bucks I have a $5
scratch off here take this it's a winner
there's got to be more of a it would
have to be I owe you three bucks for the
leg work yeah I need to wet my beak you
no I'm not I'm coming out even right
right yeah for yeah I'm not even earning
interest on my money bu five bucks is in
a bank it'd be 502 I've had people try
to give me scratch offs before sure gift
cards listen I've operated through a uh
a landscape of dirt B I myself have done
the whole store credit hey you know you
give you this that a gift card the whole
nine yards multiple gift cards you ever
get into that racket what do you mean
that's a slippery slope what you got
$351 on one gift card and $251 on
another gift card well dude I mean this
is well documented but I would get paid
in those [__] AMX my my your
Christmas Bon my Christmas bonus would
be $50 MX gift card they G they' give me
like 10 of them you didn't know them
back then you couldn't tell this kid
[__] from [__] December 15th through
January 3rd that's exactly when I got it
throw it in your face I always got it
around the it was like always the
Christmas party was always like December
15th or 14th it was nothing to shake a
stick at either they were like I think
it was 800 bucks the first year yeah and
I think a th000 the next year third year
was back down to 800 this guy rolling
around with [__] like5 $200 AMX AMX
too no they were the one year I think
they were all 25s I had like 1,400 of
them and I remember I couldn't make any
I couldn't make any playing small ball I
couldn't I couldn't make any uh large
purchases I couldn't buy any I couldn't
buy anybody gifts until I got that so
then I'd be there buying [__] you
know video games for my nephews running
through like a bunch of you know $10
gift cards by the way I just thought of
this it is the holiday
season you know it's coming
up the Christmas show mhm you know what
you're getting me I have some ideas
Toby I'm going to skip this year I think
no the [__] not no way what are you
talking about it did almost I mean you
know you stink for even saying that it
almost ruined the podcast last year not
you the the episode mainly
me yeah that's coming up that's now
let's go know I know I got some
ideas bunch of coal I don't know what
I'm
getting for me I have some ideas for you
okay you know yeah we'll see see how it
all pans out I'm putting a cigar box
again I'm going to get you the biggest
most you were getting into cigars you
[__] fat
prick I should get you some [__]
veneers close those gaps oh that'd be
great set of chompers you you guys chip
in and get me veneers no you have money
how you doing
everybody can you get them where they
look natur running around oh yeah you
can get them where they look natural
yeah yeah just running around with Bucy
face I just just my lip so I don't have
Meth
mouth yeah give me some Chompers you
guys can chip in get you some wood ones
like George Washington
maybe tastes like
Pine uh but we got to wrap it up gang a
man this was a fun one love you both why
yeah why do you say it like you say it
with a weird implicate I love you both
don't do that you're always always this
weird emotional chess game with you okay
you know I hold on why would okay's on
why would you say that no with no
nothing I was teasing Toby about his
haircut in the beginning sure but that
doesn't imply that you didn't love him I
love you buddy yeah that's like what you
say after a fight so I which makes me
think you've been fighting with us in
your head you might have got it a couple
of times yesterday I tell you who I do
love love you yeah and we'll see you
next week peace